hey guys I'd love to make a video today
I really work but I just I just haven't
got enough time I'm just way too busy
eating my banana muffin all right fine
I'll make a video Johnny it's so Charlie
it's so johnny is so good
and there we go so you're probably
wondering why I haven't been making many
videos recently I usually make a video
like every two days but at the moment I
just haven't had enough time I'm busy
doing acting the play is called being
that guy isn't actually in the play
because he's too macho for us the acting
that I'm doing at the moment is a three
week course I mean I've just finished
the first week two more weeks ago I was
hoping to get the part of Beowulf
himself I was in the shortlist with four
other guys but I didn't make it
what can you do a guy who did get the
part does have curly hair and this guy
is curly hair I don't have curly hair so
I didn't get the part
the part that I have is weird and he
asked the most random lines in the world
it's like every now and again he'll just
say something like completely out of
blue and then he'll just shut up for the
rest of the scene here's my script
Beowulf so here we go
one of my characters lines in order just
to show you how random here really is
look bear wolves warming up - I can't
see Eagle Eye I'm speechless DISA
participate not I enough nine if we said
there another look it would make a great
story
what like a giant squid it says brah
haha Earth herbal burble walk up and
then in brackets it says squid type
noises my character really is just a
strange
so I guess the play was cast accurately
then we're not landing are we are we I
thought we were just going to see I've
been hearing it all day we're on your
site though this is the famous Herod the
King's smiling a lot for someone weighed
down with grief I mean it really just
goes on like well for ages I'm sure you
know I mean it's pretty weird something
else good this happened to me recently I
bought a new computer game Resident Evil
4 Wii edition this is probably my
favorite game on the Wii and I have
Zelda I even have a Zelda t-shirt look
at that it's a game that's already being
brought out and it's just been brought
on to a different console it's just been
hiding from me and it's just amazing and
it's so freakin scary as well it's it's
unbelievably scary there's one day that
happens to be on one of the levels I'm
on at the moment where I'm just walking
around you know in this disused kitchen
area there is a lot of meat on the walls
big things of meat or rotting and
everything turn around take about a step
forward and then all of a sudden I have
nowhere this this cupboard thing it
opens up and this guy is running at me
screaming his head off and he's
completely on fire what's that you want
to see a reenactment of my reaction
something like that but I was pretty
damn scared it's just if you have a Wii
and you haven't bought that game yet go
buy it because it's just awesome I've
never stopped saying Austin that's such
an American word if you've got a Wii and
you have another game you go buy it
because it's just excellent that's a bit
better isn't it so anyway that's enough
no where's my friends gone so anyway
that's enough for today yeah see you
around guys
peace out